parking is an important service that the
council delivers we know it's important
because our customers residents and
visitors alike always mentioned parking
or whenever we consult with them in
order for us to ensure that it's
accessible the council has a team of
people who cover 74 parking sites off
street and all the enforcement on Street
throughout team bridge we do in
partnership with Devon County Council
the elements that we cover range from
strategic planning through day-to-day
enforcement and the continued processing
of penalty charge notices our permits
and cash processing at a local office we
have several make amends in place for us
to be able to deliver a seamless service
one of them is enforcement not the most
popular for everybody nobody wants to
get a parking ticket of course but if
they do our service is designed so that
it's easy for people to make an appeal
make payment the team try to go that
extra mile so their customers don't have
to the real important thing is of course
it raises 2.5 million pounds which goes
back into the countess general fund to
support other services and of course to
keep the council tax low so without
doubt parking as a service is truly
important